the Disney verse is booming with
terrifying villains who we can't help
but love and believe it or not but even
wicked villains need their go to BFFs
after all the enemy of your enemy is
your friend right we've paired up some
of the biggest fatties Disney's got to
offer watch until the end to find out
which colorful duo is a match made in
hell bhisma and gaston disney villains
are often looking for worthy sidekicks
but more often than not they wind up
disappointed
yzma from The Emperor's New Groove is as
evil as they come but she has a weakness
she loves a good looking sidekick for
this reason she allowed the adorable but
extremely dim-witted Kronk to join her
side yzma is sarcastic and ruthless but
loves a good laugh so we can't help but
think that yzma and gaston from the
Beauty and the Beast would make an
excellent pair these two friends would
be partners in crime and yzma would
definitely be proud to work with someone
as handsome as Gaston as a matter of
fact Gaston is basically an upgrade of
crong while he's just as strong he's
much smarter and criminally inclined
than yzma 'he's former sidekick but
these two would rule as equals and
gaston would use ease most magical
potions to his advantage although it's
believed that gaston perished on the
night that he ransacked the beasts
castle yzma could use her sorcery to
bring him back to life
on the plus side gaston is used to being
praised for his looks and loved being
fussed over so being in close quarters
to yzma would surely blow up his ego
these villains would bring the best out
of each other and by best we mean worse
what do you guys think could ease mind
gaston be best friends
Cruella Deville and man Cruella Deville
from Disney's 101 Dalmatians is by far
one of the most horrific and stylish
villains of all time to say that Cruella
loves fur would be an understatement
the villains only aim in life is to turn
adorable animals into fur coats and to
be frank she'll do just about anything
to get what she wants
even if that means taking young animals
away from their parents Cruella Deville
doesn't have any girlfriends in fact her
closest buds are the poachers she hires
to collect her pelts with this in mind
we couldn't imagine anyone better suited
to be Cruella's best friend than the man
from Danby the faceless man in Bambi is
also
the poacher or the hunter be sneaky and
terrifying and he shares Cruella's love
for hunting so it goes without saying
that they'd be the best of friends since
both these characters have little morals
and no regard for wildlife they would
quickly form an unbreakable bond while
we wish they could bond over tea
biscuits and cute dog pics this just
isn't their style so for the sake of the
Disney verse we truly hope these two
villains never cross paths
I want the job done tonight Jafar in
short Khan or scar
it's common for Disney characters to
have animal BFFs this is especially true
considering that many of them can talk
Jafar is one of the most disturbing
villains of all time is slow drawl and
creepy composure can be off-putting to
say the least the only person who can
get remotely close to Jafar is his
devious pet sidekick Iago problem is
Iago is small and unpowered and his
master plans aren't always the best if
you ask us Jafar is long overdue for a
villian best friend who just gets him
and since his enemies aladdin and
Jasmine have their fateful pet tiger
Rajah it's only fitting that Jafar has a
pet tiger of his own are we the only
ones who think that Jafar and Shere Khan
would be the best friends ever they
could plot evil schemes and keep each
other company problem is Sher Khan isn't
humanity's biggest advocate so it's safe
to say that these two would get off on
the wrong foot before walking on the
same path but if for any reason Shere
Khan just couldn't warm up to humans
Jafar could always try to befriend a
certain mischievous lion yes we're
talking about scar from Disney's The
Lion King come to think of it Jafar and
scar sort of have a similar vibe who do
you guys think would make a better pair
Jafar and Shere Khan or Jafar and scar
the Queen and Mother Gothel
next up is mother Gothel who many would
agree is the Disney villain we didn't
know we needed when Disney released
tangled in 2010 fans couldn't believe
how Despicable Rapunzel's alleged mother
truly was she kidnapped a baby and
imprisoned her in a tower for eighteen
long years because she was totally
obsessed with beauty does that ring any
bells there's only one other Disney
villain who would go to such great
lengths to keep her youth flowing and
that's queen grimhilde from Snow White
and the Seven Dwarves in fact
two stepmothers are so similar in spirit
that many Disney fans believe them to be
the same person
there are many clues that point to these
two having a close relationship despite
their stories taking place in different
eras both Mother Gothel and the Evil
Queen used young and beautiful girls to
get ahead in their looks Department and
they were willing to go to extreme
lengths to slow their aging process
although queen grimhilde s-- approach
was very different than mother gothel's
where certain Gothel didn't keep
rapunzel alive because she had morals
but rather because her beauty depended
on Rapunzel's vitality whereas the Evil
Queen's Beauty depended on Snow White's
demise these sorceresses would bond over
their narcissism I see a strong
confident beautiful young lady oh look
your you too lady tremaine and cnam
since dizzy can never have enough animal
sidekick friendships we thought we'd
bring another one to the table as many
of you know Lady Tremaine is princess
Cinderella's evil stepmother she made
her grand debut in 1950 when Disney
introduced Cinderella to the world Lady
Tremaine is selfish and cold-hearted
instead of taking Cinderella in as her
own daughter after her father passed
away she turned Cinderella into her own
personal maid and there was nothing lady
tremaine loved more than causing a mess
and watching Cinderella clean it up her
daughter's Anastasia and Drizella
constantly ridiculed poor Cinderella and
their cat lucifer also had a love for
making a mess of things
so now that cinderella is married and
moved out and Lady Tremaine stars have
probably followed suit Lady Tremaine
needs some new best friends to keep her
company and who better than a
troublesome pair like cnam from Disney's
Lady and the [ __ ]
this pair of sinister felines would
totally get along with Lady Tremaine
they'd love to live in a luxurious
household where an evil heiress reigns
so now that Lady Tremaine has little to
do she and her cats can torment whoever
she hires to clean their home these best
friends would have a great time together
and probably placed bets on how long it
would take for their new maids to quit
we can just see Lady Tremaine sitting on
a rocking chair with cm on either side
of her yikes now that's a frightening
sight Jay and hairy hook alright let's
shift our focus onto the descendants of
our favorite Disney villains as many of
you know the Disney Channel is famous
for its descendants for
Chai's which stars BK's like Mao Evy
Carlos and J although these BK's turn
out to be good most of them still have a
mean streak in them while J is a
stand-up guy he's been known to be a
pretty ruthless villain at times in fact
he has a reputation for being a master
thief on the Isle of the laws although
Carlos and J are best friends we can't
help but think that there's someone out
there who's far more compatible with the
son of Jafar much like J harry hook is a
vengeful and dedicated right-hand man
he's an amazing swordsman who loves his
fair share of adventure the son of
Captain Hook is arrogant and mean but
many believe this to be an act after all
it's been proven that Harry is a super
good friend and trustworthy partner just
ask kuma so are we the only ones who
think that J and Harry would be the best
pals ever not only are their style
somewhat similar but they both love to
laugh and pull around this is especially
true when it comes to play fighting for
now it looks like Harry and J are on
opposite sides of the tracks but who
knows maybe they'll become fast friends
midway through descendants 3 for now
let's focus on a villain friendship that
could very well result in the defeat of
the seven seas Captain Hook and Ursula
yes we're talking about Captain Hook in
the sea which Ursula
these nefarious villains have been
cooking up a storm since the day they
were born
they're both attracted to the sea and
love hunting mermaids and ruling over
anything that comes in their way whereas
Ursula is focused on stealing King
Triton's trident Captain Hook is
dedicated to ridding the world of the
pesky Peter Pan and since mermaids were
clearly showcased in the Peter Pan movie
we're led to believe that these villains
are a part of the same world so it's not
entirely impossible that Ursula would
stumble across Captain Hook's ship and
end up taking a liking to the
Troublesome pirate if we take the
descendants world into account then we
know for a fact that Captain Hook and
Ursula have crossed paths in the past in
fact it's possible that Captain Hook
visits Ursula as fish and chips whenever
he's hungry and seeing as Emma and Harry
Hook are super good friends it's likely
that their parents chose to raise them
side by side since it's very unlikely
that Captain Hook is Emma's father it's
safe to say that their friendship has
always been platonic together they could
rule the Seas and overpower whatever
came in their way that is unless Ariel
and Peter Pan join forces to overthrow
the villainous
IFS so do you think these two would get
along or is Ursula too busy watching
auradon soap operas to keep her
friendship afloat 80s and dr. Vasily a
now that we know which villain BFFs
would rule the Seven Seas let's take a
look at two Disney villains who would
surely rule the underworld 80s might be
a hilarious villain but he's got a bone
to pick with his older brother Zeus and
he'll stop at nothing to come out on top
although we've only ever seen Hades and
Disney's Hercules we're about to see him
take human form in the upcoming film
descendants 3 here we'll find out what
his master plan is and whether he'll be
working with dr. faciliate
do usurp or Don's throne when you think
about it Hades and dr. faciliate from
The Princess and the Frog would have the
best bromance ever both Hades and dr.
facili a work with the living the dying
and the deceased they're fond of
striking deals and watching them play
out from afar and they're always ready
to collect what's theirs
once the dealing gets done the silly a
has often made it known that he has
friends on the other side so it's very
possible that he and Hades have a
lifelong friendship that no one knows
about their friendship makes total sense
considering how hilarious they are
whereas Hades loves a good joke in some
ironic wordplay the silly a is a master
wordsmith who plays around with
sentences to trap his victims into
signing contracts we can't wait to see
these villains come to life on the
screen but that's not the only reason
we're excited to watch descendants three
Malon uma for obvious reasons we're also
curious to see how mal and umas
relationship will pan out although it's
hard to believe mal in uma used to be
best friends before mal humiliated her
in front of everyone she knew uma became
the Isles laughingstock so we're not too
surprised that she has a personal
vendetta with Maleficent's daughter now
that mal has changed her ways and become
a righteous leader uma is more furious
than ever
but what if mal gave uma along an
overdue apology would Ursula's daughter
choose to befriend her rival or would
she fight her until the very end we'd
love to see these V K's patch things up
in descendant 3 after all uma could give
evey a run for money when it comes to
the title of mouth' best friend do you
think these two villains could put their
shady past behind them and turn a new
leaf we'd like to think that forgiveness
is on the horizon
both mal and uma are such amazing
leaders it would be a pity for them to
continue fighting each other instead of
joining forces so which one of these
Disney villain BFFs do you like the best
did we miss any iconic duo's let us know
in the comments below and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited to watch descendants 3
and be sure to subscribe to the thing so
you never miss a video thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]